hey dr. John Bologna here with Ramsey
Network it's good to be back last time
we talked about how we think in pictures
and we speak in words today I want to
tell you about this thing that happened
to me when I was in grad school in this
woman Lisa Pearson who kind of changed
the trajectory of the way I deal with
myself like this idiot that I see in the
mirror right so here's what was going on
I was sitting in a graduate counseling
class so picture this there's a circle
it feels very like kumbaya like we're
all like all how's your feelings right
just how you would picture a graduate
counseling class right and we're all
talking about what would happen if you
were seeing a client for two months
three months six months and one day the
client came in and they were like you're
terrible at this like I've given you
thousands of bucks we did your little
exercise and I asked for the raise I
didn't get it and I took your advice and
she still dumped me right and I said man
that would that would devastate me in
the counseling clinic they all looked at
me like why and I said man that's like
counseling is intimate like you're
you're talking deeply with one another
that would hurt and Lisa Pearson I'll
never forget her she's a good friend and
colleague she said John they don't get
that and I was like oh gosh that was
like stupid counseling he things like
they don't get she said dude they don't
get that and here's what she said she
said you get to decide who hurt your
feelings I was like that sounds
ridiculous what do you mean by that and
she said you get to decide who hurt your
feelings nobody else that day I drove
home on my bike I rode my little bike
home and I walk in the front door and my
son Hank he's like 2 or 3 at the time he
comes out and I said hey buddy and I
went to give him a hug and he looked at
me and he said no daddy and he turned
around and ran the other way down the
hall and my first thought was yeah cuz
you suck as a dad that was my first
thought well then I thought later on
that night about what Lisa had said
about I get to choose who hurt my
feelings and then I thought
Hank is too like he doesn't get a vote
he doesn't get to hurt my feelings
and by the way his favorite game that we
play is chase he just learned how to
walk and I like to chase him around the
house and he loves it and so when I came
in to say hey buddy he wanted to play
and I took it personally so I followed
back up with Lisa and some of my
classmates and I wanted to know more
about this idea of what do you mean I
get to choose who hurt my feelings and
Lisa said she has four did four or five
people who she gave permission to hurt
her feelings and I started going through
my list and I realized I mean I give
permission to people I don't even know
to hurt my feelings I give people
permission who email me mean stuff who
edit my emails and sending back to me
who are always sending negative comments
on the interwebs or students who were
really struggling why was I inviting
them into my heart into my soul and in
my head and giving them permission to
hurt my feelings and then I started
thinking I've got friends that I haven't
talked to in 20 years I've got neighbors
that I don't really know I've got people
at my church and I started one-by-one
pulling people out so this is gonna be
kind of cheesy but no way I started
thinking about it was like this box like
who do I let into this box who'd I get
permission to hurt my feelings and so I
started taking people out I even got to
where I took out my in-laws I love my
in-laws dude I won the lottery with my
in-laws but I decided to not let him
hurt my feelings anymore they can give
me their opinions and give me their
thoughts and their dreams and their
hopes for their daughter and for me
their son-in-law for their grandkids and
then I took my parents out my parents
are incredible they both love me and I
love them but they've got their
experiences and their wisdoms and their
insights but they're not in charge of my
house need my wife are and so I took
them out and suddenly when I stopped
giving people people permission that I
didn't know or I stopped giving people
permission who loved me but who I'm not
gonna let speaking directly into my soul
when I stopped letting them hurt me
I actually was started being able to
hear them in a different way it changed
my relationship it let me love them do
because we could we could relate on a
level that wasn't about me trying to
protect myself from getting hurt but it
was I was able to say coming with tell
me what's going on your heart so my
challenge to you is this find four or
five people who you're gonna give
permission to hurt you when you do
decide on those four or five people
you're gonna get permission to hurt you
let them know and let them know to wield
that power gently let them know that you
love them too this is dr. John Bologna
signing off make sure you subscribe to
get some more genius insights and send
me an email at ask John at Ramsey
solutions calm and I'll answer your
questions directly y'all peace out have
fun and I'll talk to you soon